>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> I first met David
Remnick 22 years ago
when he was just a wisp of a boy.
I was something of a wisp
myself but I decided to call him
up when I heard that he had just
been made the Moscow correspondent
for the Washington Post.
He had come into that
position out of nowhere.
He had graduated from Princeton just
six years before and gone to work
for the Post as a night beat
police reporter, I think it was.
In time he graduated to covering
the National Football League
for the paper.
But now he was studying
Russian intently
and I being an enterprising
young editor
at a New York publishing
house decided to introduce him
to an author whose book I was about
to publish, the very talented,
irrepressibly decedent,
devastatingly acute master
of Soviet Satire, Vladimir
Voinovich.
I invited David to lunch.
We met at-- I think
it was Galileo's.
Voinovich who barely spoke
English took to David immediately.
It was a chemical thing.
David who didn't know much Russian
at the time returned the compliment.
They liked each other.
They later became friends.
It was clear that this nascent
foreign correspondent was a bright
and curious young man, a
reporter who watched and listened.
And even at that early point of his
career, it was clear he was a person
who could look past current events
to the deeper human
issues that drive them.
It's been a pleasure to
watch David ever since.
Obviously he mastered Russian
so expertly that he went
on to cover the historic events
of the crumbling Soviet Union
with great sensitivity and insight.
When communism collapsed
and glasnost
and perestroika surprised us,
David Remnick was among the
few who could explain them.
Eventually he wrote a very
good book called Lenin's Tomb
which won the 1994 Pulitzer
Prize for non fiction.
He was only 36 years old.
He had joined the New
Yorker by then.
For a while he was a staff writer.
Within six years he succeeded Tina
Brown as the editor of the magazine.
In the interim, he has been
credited with increasing circulation
by 23 percent to more than a
million readers, and he is loved
by his writers and editors and
the marketers on his staff,
all of whom feel he lives
only to please them.
Writer, editor and publisher,
David has written six
books and edited four more.
How he does it is a mystery.
Although Malcolm Gladwell,
a New Yorker staff writer
and a fellow book writer once said,
"He likes to pretend
that it's no sweat.
He cruises around and chats
with people and then disappears
and writes thousands
of words in 15 minutes.
It's all a part of that
make it look easy thing."
When asked how he could
possibly write a revealing book
about President Barack
Obama and still run one
of the most successful magazines
in the country, his wife,
a writer with the New
York Times said,
"He got up really early went back
to work after dinner with the kids
and took no weekends off and no
vacations for more than a year.
The result has been a fascinating
book that describes our president
as a man for all seasons, a
flexible mutable chameleon."
As the Post's reviewer
for book world,
Gwen Ifill of PBS described it,
"Remnick efficiently strips some
of the gloss off the
version Obama offered
in his best selling 1995 memoir
Dreams from my Father charitably
and accurately describing
that effort as a mixture
of verifiable fact,
recollection, recreation,
invention and artful shaping."
Here to talk about that book
and to illumine his theories
and observations about our man
in the White House is
the author of The Bridge.
Please welcome one of our most
dynamic American journalists
David Remnick.
[ Applause ]
>> I need to offer
two corrections as--
I guess if you're an editor you
edit everything I just I'm extremely
pleased by and flattered
by that introduction.
Let me offer two corrections one,
I did not cover the
National Football League
that would have been the Redskins.
That was way too exalted for me.
I covered the United
States Football League
and the team was the
Washington Federals.
A league that you now sadly forget
and the team went I
think two and fourteen.
And it rained every Sunday and
that was-- that was my other thing.
The other thing is the notion
of the no sweat business.
I think we can all agree safely
that this is the Schmitz capital
of the world [laughter] and let's
give ourselves a little applause
for enduring it so [applause].
And I want to thank all the
organizers of this festival.
I think you can't really imagine--
I think we can vaguely imagine why
readers would want to come here
and listen to Stacy Schiff or
Jon Franzen or Will Haygood
or whoever they happen to see in
the last hours with great enjoyment.
But you have to know
what it does for writers,
to see people that actually read,
read you, have things to say
about these books-- critical
things to say about these books,
complimentary things
about these books.
Reading is an extraordinary
activity done in quiet and solitude
as Jon Franzen has
said recently you--
reading is the one thing you
can't do seriously and multitask.
Occasions like this
though, well not reading
and maybe secondary activities are
really important to writers once
in a while to get out of the
house and meet their readers.
It does a lot for us, I know.
So I thank you for that.
I wanted-- I have just a few minutes
that I want to talk about this book
and maybe provoke a short
discussion with you and see
if I can manage to do that.
I just-- I should say a little bit
about the origins of this book,
question that I get very often has
Barack Obama wrote an autobiography?
Yes I know that, and even an awfully
good autobiography and a second book
as well that has some
virtues and also some--
I think it was utility book.
But the first book is
actually good book.
It tells a lot about of his life.
Why would you bother
writing a biography?
Well first of all,
autobiographies, memoirs are stories
that you tell about yourself.
It has the point of view of
your-- your own point of view.
You leave in and take
out what you want to do
and you would no more consider a
book on Ben Franklin authoritative
if it was called the
autobiography of Ben Franklin
as you would imagine it if it were
written by the man in the moon.
Ben Franklin is a book
that requires all kinds
of biographical scholarship and
pressure from brands and shift
and all the many people
who have concentrated
on it from different angles.
And an emerging political figure
like Barack Obama who makes use
of his own life, the
story o f his own life,
and makes it into a
political utility even,
bears biographical scholarly
and journalistic pressure
that is not his own.
So the idea to do that
book is not something
that really required
a lot of thought.
But I didn't know how much
room there was for maneuver.
As an editor and as a friend
of John Updike's I went
to his funeral a couple
of winters ago.
And on the way back from
the Massachusetts shore
where this funeral took
place, a very small service.
I stopped in at Harvard Law School
and spent a few days interviewing
law professors and colleagues
of Obama's just to see
what there was to know
after all the campaign had been
going on for quite a long time.
Many, many stories
had been written some
by some very talented journalists.
What was left over, and that
little experiment proved to me
that there was a story to tell,
a story that hadn't been told,
a story that required some depth.
Barack-- one of the
chapters in The Bridge,
the book obviously is a biography
and set against the background
and context of the racial drama of
the nation's politics and it takes
in quite a lot everything from
Harold Washington and the politics
of Chicago, the politics
of Harvard Law School,
the history of African-Americans
running for the presidency,
many different kind of subplots
in the course of the book.
But I also spent a chapter looking
at Obama's own autobiography
as a specimen of probably
the richest genre
of African-American writing and
that is African-American memoir.
In other words, I wanted to see
how this book which was written
in relative innocence, in other
words, before he became a candidate.
Before that time when
politicians write nonsense books
about themselves and bland books
about their political policies
and biographies that try to
appeal to everybody all at once.
>> This is a book written in
relative innocence and also
out of a sense of literary ambition.
The origins of his
autobiography come
when a literary agent notices
an article on the press
that this guy has become the
first African-American president
of the Harvard Law Review.
She asked him to write a book.
He doesn't know what
he's going to write.
He thinks about writing a
book about Civil Rights Law
and he happens upon his
own story and writes it.
Just like Michelle Laurice or any
number of other African-Americans
who ventured into this genre.
And I tried to look at
this book structurally,
what it sets out to do,
taking note of the fact
that there are three parts
to it, each of them ends
with the author in tears.
And it's structured apolitically.
It's in a political context but
it is not a candidate's book.
It does not take into account
Obama's life in politics
as he enters the world
of Chicago politics.
So, that was how I set
out writing this book.
I had no interest in trying to
play a catch up game of writing
about the Obama presidency.
The book ends at the
White House door.
And it examines him in all regards
prior not only to the election
but even the campaign itself gets
fairly short tripped compared
to these episodes in
Obama's youth and childhood
in his parent's development.
I just want to say one thing about
African-American autobiography,
something that it has very-- in
a very generalized way, in common
and in common with Obama's own book.
If you look at African-American
autobiography, a genre,
that begins with 6000 slave
narratives, I mean the most famous
of which is Frederick Douglas but
there are thousands of other ones,
a genre that goes straight
through to the great books
of the 20th Century, we know whether
it's Richard Wright or Malcolm X
or Maya Angelou, so many of them,
they have certain things in common,
a struggle for freedom, a journey
from either incarceration or slavery
or oppression or stifling
depending on the period of time
and historical circumstances,
a journey that tends to be part
of this and a search for
community, a search for a self,
a search for a politics,
and a search for geography
and a sense of purpose.
All these things are present
in Obama's autobiography.
The book of which-- some reviewers
have used the euphemism exhaustive
to describe this book.
What they mean is it
is 600 pages long.
And maybe occasionally
they got exhausted.
But what the goal of the book is to
separate the wheat from the chaff,
the myth from-- realities
from myths, the nonsense
and the conspiracy theories
from the facts of the matter.
It's an active journalism and
a journalism that took place
and I hope to get it out while Obama
was still in office, believe it
or not, not for commercial reasons
but as part of the project itself,
part of knowing a president
and a president's life
as best one can while
he was in office.
And here we are a year and a half
into the presidency
and what has sunk in?
Over 20 percent of the
American public believes
that Barack Obama is a Muslim as if
there were anything wrong with that,
but believes that he's a Muslim.
We still-- any audience that
I go to were very often--
I'm still asked about birth
certificates, was he really born
in Hawaii, in other words the
very fact of his existence,
his national existence is brought
under serious question
despite all the necessary
and requisite proof otherwise.
Haley Barbour, who distinguished
himself actually during Katrina one
of very few politicians who
did was interviewed recently
and it's maybe not by
mistake that he's mentioned
as a possible presidential
candidate in a couple of years.
He said that Barack Obama was
somehow, remains mysterious,
that we don't know very
much about Barack Obama.
Rush Limbaugh plays this
violin all the time,
Glenn Beck I need not
tell you plays this violin
and recently Dinesh D'Souza,
conservative intellectual,
you probably know has
come out with an article
in Fortune Magazine prefatory to
a book that's coming and proposes
that Barack Obama sees the world
through a post colonial canon point
of view and this is a view
endorsed by as brilliant by
yet another possibility for
the presidency Newt Gingrich.
And I think it is too polite
to distinguish these theories
and these points of
view with anything more
than a most harsh answer.
The fact of the matter
is Obama's born--
Barack Obama's life hides in
plain sight as does his ideology,
he is the man of the center left.
He is somebody born
where he says he is born,
very much had the life
he says he has.
Does he know people that
were way to the left of him?
Yes. Does he know people and learn
from people way to the right of him?
In law school he studied both with
Charles Fried and Roberto Unger.
That didn't make him
a Brazilian socialist
and that didn't make him
a right wing republican
in the mold of Charles Fried.
He is somebody that read
the books of Richard Posner
and was a research assistant
for a great liberal
constitutional scholar.
This doesn't make him them.
His associations do
not make him them.
And yet for political
reasons certain intellectuals,
certain politicians,
certain media outlets
and myriad websites
continue to play this tune.
I referred earlier and I'll
make this a concluding point,
I referred earlier to the genre
of African-American autobiography.
One of the distinguishing
features of slave narratives is
that slaves wrote to
prove their literacy,
their personhood, their
independence.
And yet they had to have
very often the books endorsed
by white abolitionists.
If you look at the title page
of Frederick Douglas'
autobiography it has a gesture
from William Lloyd Garrison saying
this book was actually written
by believe it or not
by Frederick Douglas.
That's where we were
in the 19th Century.
And yet on the internet, on Rush
Limbaugh and elsewhere there cropped
up the theory that Barack
Obama wasn't even capable
of writing the book that he wrote.
We heard theories that Barack
Obama was not the author
of his own biography
but who was its author?
Wait for it-- Bill Ayers.
Well if this was just one
isolated website it wouldn't worth
distinguishing in an audience like
this but that is where we are,
and Barack Obama's life is still
in play as a political weapon.
I'll stop there and why
don't we have some questions
from the audience.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Sure.
>> Hi, thanks.
Is this working?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, I mean the scurrilous
smears that you've alluded
to here are shocking,
they're repelling,
they're disgusting its' a shame
that this is taking place
at the present time.
However, it's not utterly unique
in American history
or American politics.
>> No.
>> Look at the election of
1800, the 1850's, 1930's,
you could pick almost any
decade and find if not identical
at least somewhat comparable
scurrilousness
in alleged political discourse.
So--
>> But what distinguishes it is
that he's an African-American
in the White House.
This makes everything a
little bit more electrifying.
little bit more pointed.
So, when we hear rhetoric like
we want to take our country back,
when we hear rhetoric directed
at Obama and his otherness
and the mystery of his background
and the very purposeful fudging
at best of the facts of the matter,
it takes on an outsized importance
and an outsized danger I'd say.
Yes?
>> I just wanted to ask you, did
you get any input or any comments
from President Obama
himself from this book?
>> Yeah I interviewed Barack Obama.
Both before he was president and
in the White House but I should say
that was great, that was nice, it
certainly didn't hurt but that's not
where the good stuff comes from as
a biographer and as a journalist.
The good stuff comes from spending
a couple of days with somebody
who spent a couple of years
going to McDonalds and being
in endless boring meetings and being
a community organizer with him.
That's where the good
stuff tends to come.
For example, you know at this
time, at this point an interview
with Obama is very slowed
down, purposeful, deliberate,
the goal of which is to
be somewhat informative
but also to make no false steps.
And there are-- for obvious
political reasons for that.
I don't blame him.
Yup.
>> Hi, the August 30th issue of the
New Yorker contains a puzzling piece
of commentary that I was hoping
you could help me understand.
A man looks up at judge
who will decide his case
and the judge says small
potatoes is no defense.
Could you explain this to me?
>> I can't hear.
>> It was the-- a cartoon in where--
>> Oh I don't want to get
into cartoon explanation.
>> Okay.
>> You know at the end of the
year we have a cartoon section
in the special cartoon issue
that comes out in November
and it's called I Don't Get It.
>> Okay.
[ Laughter ]
>> And we ourselves publish
cartoons a second time realizing
that maybe they didn't get it
in the first place and I want
to take full responsibility for
that because I'm the judge and jury.
Look it is true I was
a foreign correspondent
in Moscow, I'm very proud of that.
I'm also the judge and jury
on New Yorker cartoons.
So I bear full responsibility
and whatever jail term
comes with that [laughter].
Yes, sir.
>> I'm really curious about this
Dinesh D'Souza piece that's gotten
so much attention and
what you make of it.
And first of all of the irony that
this is someone who is developing
to give the intellectual
clause of or imprimatur
to these other scurrilous arguments,
an argument about post colonialism
when, you know, he is too a son
of immigrant parents from India.
>> This whole country
is post colonial--
>> Yeah and the whole
country is post colonial,
this is exactly my point.
>> Look I can't answer for
Dinesh D'Souza and I want
to read the full book but I, this--
>> What I'm asking is--
>> This notion that somehow Obama
inherited his father's ideology
could not be farther from the truth.
Obama if anything, Obama's father
was a counter example for him.
>> Uh hmm.
>> A counter example in the sense
that Obama's father was a highly
intelligent man but dissolute,
lacking discipline, in
fact blew his life up.
A really difficult man at
best, violent at worst,
really not anything resembling
what you and I would call
as they say a "family man".
And ideologically if you're gonna
call somebody that's surrounded
by Larry Summers and Tim
Geitner and Christina Romer,
et cetera a post colonial socialist,
then you haven't studied
hard enough.
Let's move on.
>> Well then why doesn't
someone call him out on that?
>> Okay thank you.
>> Yes, I was born and
raised in the South.
I graduated from college as
classmate with Newt Gingrich.
I've also lived in Hawaii
in a multiracial society
and I've often wondered if Obama who
grew up in this multiracial society
in Hawaii, had international
exposure can he possibly understand
the vitriol of southern
white anger toward him
as I can having come
from that culture.
>> You know I'm not a novelist
and when I say I'm not--
what I mean by that is a novelist
because here she is making it
up can go as deep as that
imagination can reach.
I think no biographer or journalist
can pretend to reach that deeply.
Certainly Obama has read widely in
the history of race, in the history
of civil rights, he knows
these things from a distance,
he is also a black man in America
and has felt the sting of prejudice
as well as any black man or
woman has sooner or later,
no one escapes uninjured
in some way or another.
But if you read his own book and
my own reporting reflects this,
growing up in Hawaii in a so
called multicultural Hawaii even
at this very elite prep school
that he went to was no picnic, why?
Because there is a very
prideful multiculturalism except
for one thing there are
hardly any black people there.
Most of the African-Americans
in Oahu are on a military base.
And if you read his book and my own
reporting bore this out and I talked
to all his black classmates
he felt the sting of prejudice
as a young guy very acutely.
Was it like being a black kid in
1954 in Philadelphia, Mississippi?
No, but it had its
own particularities.
Yes sir?
>> Yeah I have just a question of--
>> Well I think we don't have much
time so if-- quickly as we can.
>> Oh yeah sure really quickly,
so I've tried to explain
for myself what I see is the
president is naive taint dealing
with the republicans and his
unwillingness to talk in terms
like Franklin Roosevelt
talked during the depression
and really characterizing as FDR did
very clearly the deceptions, the--
and building up very exquisitely
his own rejections of the right
and how the right was
criticizing his reaction and--
>> But the president can't do
everything no matter how exalted the
rhetoric and it is curious that
Obama's rhetorical capacity
as president have not been always
on the level of it as a campaigner
but as poetry prose dichotomy
there that you know well.
In fact, this administration
took off
on a little mini attack
on Fox News for example.
It petered out very, very quickly.
There is this kind of division
of people talking to themselves
and riling each other up.
I would argue that it's more
intense and more pernicious
on one side than the other.
It's too polite to me to say that
it's all evenhanded, it's not.
And it's very, very powerful thing
and it's not easily
defeated or overcome.
>> I guess my question is more--
>> Wait this will be
the last question.
>> Okay.
>> You've been a daily
journalist and you've gone along
for magazine journalism and
later a book and the research
and the writing behind
all those forms is--
could be quite different
although some similarities.
I was wondering about
the process that you go
through with your writers
in the editing process
and how you recommend that
they do their research
and writing for the New Yorker.
It has a bit influence
by your daily--
>> But I want to make
one thing very clear.
>> Sure.
>> I'm the editor of the magazine
but I'm not the only editor
at the magazine and there are
extraordinary editors, Henry Finder,
Dorothy Wickenden and Daniel
Zalewski, people that you may
and more who you may not know or you
may, who are extraordinarily gifted
in doing what editors
do and what do they do?
They try to help a writer find
a way to maximize what it is
and make better what it is
that the writer set out to do.
Not what the editor is imposing but
try to get inside a piece enough
and it happens through a long
relationship with the writer,
to make that thing better, to find--
to help in whether it's structural
or intellectual or word by word
to make as beautiful and as clear
and as forceful a piece
of writing can be.
So, and all people do it in
different ways and it has to do
with an extension of
their personalities
and the intellect they
bring to the table.
So, there is no one way of doing
this, just as there's no one way
of being a baseball manager
or a teacher or any one thing.
Listen, thank you all for coming
out here I know it's
extraordinarily hot [applause]
and it does us all a lot of good.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]